[Music]
we all know the magic mushroom houses in
the tight white pants excuse me
but what if there were more to the story
I saw someone who looks like guy
what is the loft villages in the legend
I was wrong
if there really are other Smurfs temple
we moved the fire left whatever you do
don't eat all your rations so I got all
my rather is this pace
wow wow wow we have to find the village
before they do I'll be like Baba they'll
be all like oh that's what I call pocket
out of your butt
I'm really freaking out you guys
Murray the lost village yes the lost
village this is cool I wouldn't touch
that if I were you
well Mallory you said that all I want to
do is touch it guys
now
you